welcoming back to this program is a
demand of pride of Penn State University
in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania and also one
of the stars a better call Saul playing
Howard Hamlin airing Mondays at 9:00
Eastern Time on AMC Patrick Fabian good
to see you again brother hey yeah I'm
good I'm good I mean we're in the midst
of the sky falling rightfully so but
other than that and I know I'm happy to
be here to promote my tell them I
appreciate that you are here in person I
appreciate that for sure and it's good
to see you you look well and
everything's going well I I'm good I
have to say you know I'm gonna do it my
green I'm in California and so you got
to your green juice everyday it's sort
of like a requirement if you're in the
business getting through all that I
didn't get my yoga in but I did do my
swimming at the public pool today which
was great
I'm gonna go there as long as I can
because it's me and all of the old all
the old Russian guys who live in my
neighborhood right yeah it's great it's
a great Posse to hang with that sounds
like the worst reboot of Cocoon ever
that is just a dreadful cocoon reboot
right there well the locker room scenes
are very I don't know the Russian who
plays Wilford Brimley's must be a little
bit a little man I'm loving better call
Saul brother it's just as good as ever
it just doesn't stop Thanks it must be
amazing to be on a set and just see
these scripts come in from from
obviously Vince Gilligan and Peter Gould
and the whole writing staff is fantastic
you know I am I'm on the show obviously
so I'm a homer but right you know we're
in our fifth season a lot of times you
know shows can dip they can have the
jump of the shark and all that sort of
thing and I just don't think these
writers have done it they've just keep
getting better and better and I think
part of that is the cumulative effect of
us watching it and being behind Jimmy
and watching him turn into Saul and even
those only there's only ten episodes per
season right
I think that's late itself into they're
all good episodes and now we're in
season five or seen Jimmy get really
what he saw now he is so small
completely with the suits and everything
else right and so but just not with his
office yet we haven't gotten him he's
not totally down the full no Saul
Goodman wormhole just yet no but
watching him embrace it you know the
highest compliment I can give him I
think I meant to call Bob about this my
mother mm-hmm in Pennsylvania yes her
and my dad watched the show every Monday
night at 10 o'clock because they have a
DVR but of course they don't know
operated and so they wake up after
watching the show you know and she
called me and she goes you know I saw
Bob on Kelly and Ryan and he was so
different than he is on the show he's a
really good actor
so I pass on Mary Lou Fabian's
compliment you know I did did Mary Lou
think he's gonna be handing out 50% off
felony cards to the Ryan and Kelly
audience or something no I think her
usual comment to me was this after she
watches the show she calls him she goes
oh she goes you looked really good are
you gonna have any more to do now and I
have to explain to her that it's called
better call Saul it's never gonna be
called better call to Howard that's
right right but you gotta love it I'm
just like Bob it's actually a really
good show believe me it's fantastic it's
very successful this is a good job I
love that I love that and he's tossing
bowling balls at your car this time an
episode you know what more people
tweeted at me about how they were sad
about my car than they were about like
me right emotionally they're just like
oh dude sorry about the Jag right who's
who's the one on the set that is most
close to the character that they portray
well Rhea seehorn would say it would be
me because Howard's vainglorious and
peacock right that's why she would be
wrong of course I don't know do you
really want to meet Michael mando in a
dark corner no I don't think so I don't
think you're listening I love your
brother you know that he's been great
not just you know he's getting
untethered as well right now and you
know the addition of Tony Dalton is Lalo
as big friend rain right because he's
this he's this weird wire of energy with
that great smile that seems very
disarming that makes you think like
others there's no malice in him when of
course there's all this awfulness
underneath it we also know Giancarlo
Esposito is not Gus fring he has come on
the show almost as many times as you
have and he is a delightful right
individual yes talk about a good actor
my mother should know that how good of
an actor he is as well because honestly
he comes in here and there was at one
point though there was one point though
where I did ask him a question about how
long does it take him to get into Gus
fring right uh-huh
and he didn't flip me that look and I'm
like oh my gosh you do not like to be on
the receiving end of that luck do you no
I didn't like it at that point in time
but I have absolutely just enjoyed the
whole shootin match so far this year I
said to Jonathan banks a couple years
ago I was just like oh man I I really
hope we have a scene together and he
immediately goes no you don't you don't
wanna stand with me Patrick okay and I
was like you know what maybe on second
thought yeah we can hold that off into
the final season John I love you you
know that Jonathan I love you he's been
in so many great things we met him at
the Red Cross golf tournament that he
absolutely he was in 48 hours how about
that he was that he was the the you know
Nick Nolte's partner who gets killed yet
his bailing of 48 hours he looks great
by the way he looks almost exactly the
same sort of 60 when he was 20 I think
right I know that Patrick Fabian here on
the Rich Eisen show what do you think of
your Steelers season man I mean they
were they were they were better than
anybody expected or could expect
absolutely that's coaching up I think
it's not a doubt I think I think maybe
the last couple years maybe he was
losing control of the team in some
respects right right and I think this
was a great opportunity to remind us why
he is the coach for the Steelers he's
the right coach for this deal is amazing
right you could say this is Mike
Tomlin's best coaching ever oh he didn't
he didn't get coach of the year I think
it is enough what only thing is that eat
read ate Nate it's just okay that you
can't really reward that enough to give
a but to say you were eight Nate and you
should have been five and 11 easily I
know easily and you know I appreciate
Pittsburgh fans
embracing the rotating quarterbacks
trying to make him you know trying to
put them on their shoulders I loved
watching Minka Fitzpatrick that was a
great deal I know on draft day of course
we're gonna go like Oh number 5 shoe the
booth ours but no I think for the
long-term I like that he's there no I
mean he he's exactly the type of guy
that you go against type and give up a
first-round draft choice in a future
draft with their steel
never do twice and just showed you that
they knew they had to hit this defense
and get it shored up better to get to
where they want to go yeah by for the
first time in the Superbowl draft era
trading up ten spots in the first round
to get Devon Bush and then three weeks
into the season because the fire sale
was on in South Florida go and flip a
first in the future year which they
never do for Fitzpatrick and I can see
what those two guys two kids did in that
second and third parts you know levels
of the defense how they were able to
work with tha want Gohan save it saves
the season it sets a that's the the mold
for the next five to ten years to come
it's gonna be I'm hopeful and also you
know depending on how Big Ben is on his
return you know I clearly we're no where
in the last quarter of the of our Big
Bend time so I in the future
I mean we're gonna need a QB at some
point I know I don't know if I don't
know if the duck is is the man duck or
Mason Rudolph to you know and I like
them both and I thought they both were
did as well as they could in a moment
that they certainly didn't expect I
don't think you know you ever really
think that Ben's gonna go down and
you're gonna come in like that but uh
you know other defenses got their number
pretty quick I know Patrick Fabian of
better call Saul here on the Rich Eisen
show look if I had told you okay the
first brown Bellus season would also be
Big Ben loose from the middle of the
second game on Wow and you would get
Mason Rudolph out there and he would not
be ready for primetime and would get
injured to the point duck Hodges would
get out there
duck Hodge and you'd still be eight and
eight now that's a bet that that's
whoever took that bet was really smart
right now speaking of bets I knew this
was gonna come up I know you were hoping
that Patrick Fabian would bring gifts
like the last time and I didn't
appreciate that yeah iiiii I recall that
I brought you all some some bets from
Vegas because it was there yeah they
gave you a Michigan you gave me a
Michigan wins the national championship
one which I realized you know probably
around Thanksgiving wasn't gonna catch
what's gonna happen but you don't hope
springs eternal I think I gave her
Cleveland Browns out there as well to
someone
unsure it was a long shot and by the way
shout out to Shannon Simon my friend
who's a just discovered I've known her
for 20 years and she just discovered I
was a Steeler fan by listening to your
promo and listening to your show how
does somebody who's known you for 20
years not know you know what we haven't
hung out I guess during football season
enough or she hasn't seen my closet
enough I don't know it Browns like 50 to
1 or the browser 15 to 1 they did not
win last year but hope springs eternal
as they say Judy was 2 years ago
probably been better odds in 50 to 1
last year with Baker and Odell Janis and
all that everyone was putting them in
the playoffs before the season did you
know why they might be ok this year
after the after they had after they can
we say the bed after you can't say that
no ok after they had a doo doo in the
bed in the bed yes very you must have
enjoyed that one immense oh yeah
especially because we were suffering as
well right we were suffering and then to
watch that just implode right after all
that talk now view however did bring a
ticket for Christopher's and this might
make me a I don't know they might throw
me out of Steeler Nation I did bring a
winning ticket for the New England
Patriots to win the Super Bowl that was
two years ago that the Patriots went
ahead and cashed yeah big winner yeah I
guess the winner against the against the
Rams yeah now how much did you make off
of that was a $5 ticket thank you sir
yes eight to one ah queered 45 bucks is
there any well that's lunch money right
there any vigorish for our friend
Patrick yeah don't know where it is
oh no I haven't actually been able to
cash it are you kidding me are you
kidding me money money never let me to
see you know you never by the way he's
breaking news to me too oh wow you let's
break my bad news even touch it by the
way when I brought it to you you didn't
even touch it for the sense of
impropriety you're like just so you know
this is a sealed envelope I have no idea
what you're talking about for the
University of Michigan it's around here
somewhere
Wow we've got a lot of
refrigerator it's on a magnet somewhere
that there's no way that exists anymore
but I got bad news for you I have not
made a Vegas trip I was unable to make
you a bet for the upcoming season but
that's alright Brady's not resigning
there anyways that he's gonna be a
charger isn't he
but instead I'm gonna make you all how
to marry members of HHS I've gotta go
I've got a Hamlin notepad Wow pens HHM
pens great I love this Hamlin Hamlin &
McGill so there you go now you're afraid
you can write down all your faucet you
know you could write down your poetry
you know late at night with your hand
you could take your future winning
tickets and just put them right again
cannot believe you did not catch that
I'm like so Patrick's coming in later on
this week and he goes do you think he'll
bring me another singer boy ticket to
cash you know then technically I cannot
be thrown out of Steeler Nation because
since the ticket was not cashed I have
not crossed that heretical line by
actually rooting for the Patriots how
about that I'll take that I'll bend it
that way like Fabian do you think your
coach is still gonna stick around Penn
State Franklin's gonna be coming back
one more year obviously but every year
we keep hearing out here in Los Angeles
that the Trojans in a knock on his door
hey I hope he stays I think you know
he's the right coach
for that school right and he's done such
a fine job with them and you know I was
a lot to put on your back right
you know the interim coach who was there
for a year down in texans No yeah yeah I
mean thankless job I mean he got that on
the straight and narrow
yeah and clearly showed his chops to be
a head coach in the in the big leagues -
yeah so it worked out great but it was
good that I have just a moment with him
and then Franklin is the future I think
I would hate to see him come all the way
to USC no it's my backyard okay before I
let you go sir I I it's so tough to ask
these questions of a member of the show
like better call Saul cuz I kind of know
what the answer is gonna be but what can
you tell us about the next six episodes
then except you can drop a breadcrumb or
two that will not have let me ask you
though I can tell you know I can tell
you I can tell you things are gonna get
crazy crazy sometimes it's a nice lawyer
show with some emotional problems and
there's some threats of violence - and
there's some other things there's a few
seasons worth slow-burn yeah yeah
absolutely
and no I think the snowball goes rolling
down the hill hard this time and there's
a particular episode I think I can say
this okay there's a particular episode
with Jonathan and Bob that is just
jaw-dropping / Vince later on in the
season rented by Vince Gilligan yes I
can and and Saul Goodman have I will say
there they have a scene or two that it
will that'll be extremely satisfying to
everybody okay now we also got the
return of Hank I know and Gomez you know
from Breaking Bad yeah that was great
it's great to see them how fun is it to
see them I love it
Dean Norris is truly I mean to see Hank
does he Hank alive right and that's the
right thing you're like oh you're right
Hank and Gomi are there they're alive
and it's great I know that look the
whole that's what the thing is about
better call salt with the exception of
Saul okay cuz obviously we see the
flashbacks to him in black and white at
thrive every season too much /wel the I
guess the flash-forward yeah or the
present day not a flash day the rest of
it's a flashback I will say this and
even though I know that Breaking Bad has
been out there but it's been out there a
long time
think about Susie and I my wife and I
remark watching better call Saul is the
number of people on the screen that we
know that they are escaping and cheating
death and being at
skirting on the edge of of putting
themselves in harm's way that eventually
when they run into Walter White
he offs them all like he gets them yeah
absolutely all of them and that's the
amazing thing about this show so I ask
you are we done
seeing Breaking Bad characters from
yesteryear on this season oh that no I
want to keep my job I can't say anything
about that you know what I can't say
okay tune in to AMC on Monday nights to
find out well done well see I knew I
knew I knew at some point I would I
would push it do you have to say looking
for job security my friend can't do any
of that Mondays at 9:00 Eastern Time on
AMC better call Saul starring Bob
Odenkirk Jonathan banks Rhea seehorn
Michael mando Giancarlo Esposito and you
Patrick Fabian just to name a few just
it's it's really great
are you have you spent the last two
three minutes searching looking for it
he's literally the Gronk's around here
something I'll tell you what if you do
take a picture and post it for me so I
can see or at least get it back to Vegas
honey it's it's not forever it doesn't
last forever right isn't there I
wouldn't it it's a winning ticket
there aren't it's not like a cheque that
after snow and now I think it's okay I
think you might be right I think it's it
lasts forever
well because forever the result is still
the result right I don't know go back
and give the win they can make it many
of their rules if you were running the
casino wouldn't you say you have a year
to claim it it's not our money
this sounds like Albert Brooks and lost
in America go to the casino boss to get
going up to us our money back yeah going
up to Garry Marshall to basically say
you know you've got a kid now you need a
nest egg I do I need to check I did it's
like after the Pats won so seriously
like let's show it somewhere dude let's
just let's just extrapolate this out
let's say you've got a winning ticket
from Super Bowl 13 you're gonna walk in
you're gonna walk in a circus circus
which still exists and say this ticket I
found it in my attic I need to cash it
but if you
from the sands it doesn't exist anymore
no that's so that's the way that one
went but if the casino still exists it
should be able to be cashed any it feels
like although it does feel like Circus
Circus might be the one this is how to
just pick out a casino that I know is
still around a little in size it in his
vacation I couldn't see the Bellagio
because the BLA she wasn't around in
Super Bowl xxxii right here no good good
pic good thing you still looking through
his belongings Chris you're not gonna
find it it is gone it's gone it's gone
you remember coming at you you've
restored my station status I'll take it
but doesn't that just sound but one of
the best scenes albert brooks and lost
and i really understood what a nest egg
really was the desert has heart oh my
god this desert has heart oh my gosh
Hamlin and Hamlin & McGill
Patrick Fabian check out again better
call Saul fifth season and thank
goodness it's been renewed for 6th
unfortunately that is a the final season
but Mondays at 9:00 Eastern Time on AMC
thanks for coming out here privately
thank you Elle